president Trump appears to be fleeing
the early presidential primary debates
here is his advisor Jason Miller going
on TV explaining why the president's
probably not going to come at the moment
president Trump has indicated that he's
unlikely to participate at least in the
first two debates he's up by 30 40 and
even new polling shows he's up by almost
50 percent in certain places it really
wouldn't make much sense for him to go
and debate right now with a bunch of
folks who are down at three four and
five percent even Rhonda Sanctus who's a
second place candidate in the race
currently is at least 20 30 or 40 points
behind and so ultimately president Trump
will make a decision as we get closer he
has not said anything definitive one way
or the other I'm not expecting him to
participate though
there you go top advisor to Trump saying
I'm not
or rather Trump is not likely to go to
the debates there's a candidate for him
in Iowa tomorrow
all the candidates are going to be there
Donald Trump is not going to be there so
there seems to be evidence he's going to
make good on this threat Trump's critics
in the Republican Party Liberal
Republicans like Chris sununu in New
Hampshire they are pouncing on Trump and
saying he looks like a wimp
former president Trump the tough guy the
guy that says he's going to fight for
America and fights for but he's not
willing to stand up he's going to wimp
out wimp out and not get on that debate
stage we don't know for sure anything
yet he's gonna wimp out that that clown
that child that coward why won't he get
on the debate stage
why would he
why would he I don't want you to shoot
the messenger here okay I'm not working
for any campaign I have told you I do my
level best not to endorse in primary
campaigns I think I might be the only
conservative pundit in America right now
who is not actively working for one of
the presidential campaigns I like pretty
much all of the candidates in the field
I know a great number of them personally
and I have a great deal of respect for
for all of the ones that I know and even
for some of the ones that I don't know
so I'm just calling it like I see it
fellas and you cannot like the message
you can be angry about these political
facts on the ground but I'm just telling
you what it is
Trump has no incentive to debate right
now he has no incentive I've got the
real clear politics average of polling
Trump is up according to the RCP average
Trump is up
32.4 points
now the RCP average is a very reliable
fairly conservative average of polls
that includes morning consult Economist
Yuga Fox Emerson NBC Yahoo Harvard
Harris CNN the messenger Harris Expo
we've got all of them there Trump is
crushing the field
32.4 is the average Harvard Harris has
him up 45 points over the rest of the
field this is a 10 person field
it's not even close
so with a commanding lead like that that
he does not appear to be losing in fact
his lead only appears to either remain
the same or to be increasing as his most
intense and serious primary Challenger
seems to be losing ground
why on Earth would Trump get on that
stage
well because the voters have a right
they demand the right to see the
candidates debate they don't demand that
if those poll numbers start to change
then that will indicate that the voters
are demanding that but as of now the
voters seem to be extraordinarily
supportive of Trump without seeing him
debate the other candidates well but
they the voters should demand it well
maybe you think they should demand it
but they're not demanding it right now
well I just think it's the right thing
to do okay
maybe you would prefer that Trump get on
the debate stage I would prefer it in
many ways because it would give me more
content for my show and I'm sure it
would be extremely entertaining
but there is no moral imperative for
Donald Trump to engage in a primary
debate
and there is no law that says he has to
do it and there is no particular rule in
the Republican party that says he has to
do it
I'm sure the Republican Party would
prefer that he'd do it but don't forget
Trump engaged in a hostile takeover the
Republican Party Trump doesn't give a
damn what the party apparatchics want
right now go to expressvpn.com Knowles
profiling surveillance and data
harvesting are a few things that you
probably don't like very much about the
tech Giants what can you actually do
about it when you rely on so many of
their products well the good news is
doesn't take much for you to take a
stand for less than seven bucks per
month you can join me and fight back
against big Tech by using expressvpn how
do you think big tech companies make all
their money anyway well by tracking your
searches video history and everything
you click on and then selling your
personal data expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address a unique
identifier that every device has that
allows big Tech to match your activity
back to you that is why expressvpn is
the only VPN that I use and Trust on all
of the devices to make it much more
difficult for them to exploit my data
for their own profits and the best part
is it's so easy even I can use it I'm a
bit of a Luddite you just click one
button on your phone on your computer on
your tablet turns it on keeps people out
of your business time to fight back go
to expressvpn.com Knowles get three
extra months for free expresvpn.com
Knowles expressvpn.com Knowles to learn
more right now go to hillsdale.edu
Knowles or you a few years or maybe a
few decades out of school and wondering
what did I even learn and what was the
point you might think to yourself that
you don't have the time to learn
something new well if that's you then
know this you're not alone it's not too
late since 1844 Hillsdale College has
been providing education in faith
freedom and character they've taken some
of the core classes they teach on campus
and made them available for free online
for anyone who wants to learn that is
right for free there are 39 free courses
to choose from ranging from the
Constitution the Book of Genesis free
market economics and so on they're easy
to follow they're self-paced so you can
start whenever you want in fact you can
start right now it's everything you need
all in one place with no long-term
commitment let Hillsdale College be your
guide learn when and where you want go
right now to hillsdale.edu Knowles to
enroll no cost it's easy to get started
hillsdale.edu Knowles to register
hillsdale.edu Knowles if the other
candidates want Donald Trump to debate
they have to create the political
circumstances that force him to debate
and the way to create those political
circumstances is to knock his poll
numbers down if the other candidates
cannot knock his poll numbers down
then Trump's showing up on that debate
stage presents all risk and no upside
that's how politics works
candidates
have one goal in a campaign and that is
to win the race the race right now is
not against Joe Biden the race is for
the Republican Party nomination you
might say well I just think Trump's not
going to be a good general election
candidate doesn't matter that's not what
we're asking right now well I just think
he's he looks cowardly maybe he does and
if enough voters think that he looks
cowardly for ditching the debates that
will be reflected in the polls and then
he will be forced to engage in the later
debates but right now I'm just I'm not
prescribing anything I'm not advocating
anything I'm just telling you why it is
the case that Trump
is inclined not to engage in the debate
he has very little to gain and quite a
lot to lose now on the other side of
this look at the Democratic party Joe
Biden is up 54 points on his next most
serious primary arrival RFK Jr
so this is a Kennedy albeit a somewhat
kooky one this is a mainstream Democrat
who's been in public life for a long
time Biden's up 54 points on him Trump
is not quite up 54 points but he's up a
similar amount on his nearest primary
arrival and don't forget there are three
candidates right now in the Democrat
field it's Biden
Bobby Kennedy and Marianne Williamson
who's much lower
if Biden's not going to debate which he
almost certainly is not then why would
Trump debate we might say well because
Biden is the incumbent and Trump's not
the incumbent yeah kind of kind of
we have not had a one-term president run
for a rematch in over 130 years
the last President to do it was Grover
Cleveland
it's only happened once in American
history that a president won
non-consecutive terms
so I grant you
Trump is not literally the incumbent
here
but practically speaking
for most intents and purposes Trump is
the incumbent you might say well he
shouldn't be treated that way that's
wrong that's not I'm not telling you
what should or should be whatever I'm
just explaining I am describing to you
why the circumstances in this primary
are different from the other primaries
you can like that you cannot like that
you can pull your hair out and scream to
the heavens
if you don't accept those political
realities you're going to become
increasingly frustrated as this
inevitably unusual primary unfolds boy
what a great clip that was it was great
I know I know well if you want more of
them and if you want long-form
interviews and if you want the yes or no
game if you want all the show and if you
want everything you gotta ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time